um
okay it says it's going live
and we are now live so let's kick off
folks today is going to be an extremely
exciting conversation we have Grady
booch unfortunately the internet has
just gone down where Grady lives so he
has heroically joined on his mobile
phone using the mobile phone network so
it's it's fantastic that we can still do
this but Grady boots is a renowned
computer scientist known for advancing
software engineering and architecture
co-authoring the unified modeling
language
uml and founding the agile Alliance as
Chief scientist for software engineering
IBM research Grady leads IBM's research
and development on embodied cognition as
an IBM fellow ACM fellow and IEEE fellow
he's authored numerous books and
Technical articles now Grady's current
work includes architecting complex
software intensive systems space related
projects and studying the mind's
architecture and design patterns
moreover he's producing a transmedia
documentary exploring the intersection
of computing and The Human Experience so
it's a true honor to have Grady on the
podcast with us today
um Connolly he is the CEO of conjecture
and was the ex-lead and co-founder of a
lifer AI now Connolly he is an AI
researcher working on understanding
large ml models and aligning them to
human values Conor has said coming into
this that he's interested in hearing
counter arguments to his current view
that we should be taking existential
risk from AI extremely seriously and
Grady butcher said that he hasn't
written much on this particular topic
because he finds it a bit of a
distraction but he would like to use
today to find common ground and explore
points of disagreement now this isn't
technically a debate this is a friendly
discussion although we're going to have
some formal structure at the beginning
just to make sure that the positions are
clearly understood so without any
further delay we're going to kick off
with 8 to 10 minutes both from Grady
first and then Connor with rebuttals
thereafter and I think we're going to
gravitate into more of a normal
conversation after that and take some
audience questions at the end
um I forgot to ask you Grady can we do
are we doing 60 Minutes Or 90.
90 minutes work for me I have nothing
until about Tuesday Thursday morning so
I'm happy to keep going at it for a
while wonderful well um Grady boots your
opening statements and welcome to mlst
Tim thank you for the opportunity and
Connor a delight to interact with you
is AI an existential risk absolutely not
does AI present to us Clear and Present
other kinds of risks absolutely
now Conor in reviewing some of your
materials I think you and I do have
common ground
I believe we both agree that AGI
artificial general intelligence is a
term that's ill-defined and often
misused and abused
I believe we also agree that human
intelligence is not unique indeed there
are probably other kinds of
intelligences and yet looking at it
through the lens of humanity it's
difficult for us to imagine otherwise I
will make an aside and say living here
in Maui I spent a lot of time with
cetacean researchers and I have had many
events where I've looked at a whale a
humpback whale eye to eye and you can
tell that there is an i thou experience
going on there is the presence of
another
there's the classic paper what does it
feel like to be about I'd like to see
one about what does it feel like to be a
whale because clearly there is an
intelligence there
I think you and I are both Engineers I
heard your story of reverse engineering
gpt2 that was kind of cool and I think I
believe the common ground as you and I
also worry more about building real
things as opposed to discussing
philosophical things as to how many
angels can dance on the heatsink of a
GPU
I think we also agree that regulation
should focus upon use not a particular
technology
that being said I think you and I do
have some profound areas of disagreement
my understanding and you can correct me
a lot or as we go along here I believe
that you believe that large language
models are capable of General problem
solving my point of views is that large
language models are actually
architecturally incapable of any kind of
reasoning and therefore a long way off
from any kind of threat
I also infer and I want to discuss this
did you have far less confidence than
the resilience of the human spirit and
its attendance to large shocks we'll
talk about that indeed I wrote about
this in aftershocks which is a follow-on
to the book Future Shock written some 50
years ago and I spoke about that very
topic
so before I outline my points of view my
position I need to give you some context
uh Tim thank you for that introduction
I would summarize it by saying that I'm
largely an architect so I'm looking at
the lens of this particular issue
through the lens of an architect and
that being said I've been involved in
shaping the form and function of quite
literally thousands of systems across a
multitude of domains and this is most
important across risk risk profiles
I was first attracted to AI when I was
12 Built My Own first computer when I
was 12 or that would have been 1967. I
studied SRI shaky at the time from which
the a-star algorithm came
uh gray Walters Elmer and Elsie were
high in my list of things that I studied
Minsky snark was around that time and I
poured into Weiner's cybernetics and all
the writings around that
I've been working in the space of AI for
the last 10 years I first worked with
Watson I was not part of the Watson team
but I was brought in bringing my
architectural skills to document the as
built architecture
I then in my space work began to work
with NASA on its Mission to Mars and we
were building out a neurosembolic
architecture whose purpose was twofold
first to drive the robots on the surface
of Mars that led us to some work with
soul machines and and uh major oil and
gas company out of Australia who has
similarly hostile missions on oil rigs
and it also led us to build an effect to
Hell you'll see a howl blow over here
someplace behind me minus the homicidal
use cases
and there was the Mayflower an
autonomous vessel that moved itself from
the across the North Atlantic and the
last five years I've been working on a
project called synagi where I'm working
with a set of neuroscientists not
computer scientists who were trying to
look at the architecture of the brain
through the lens of Neuroscience indeed
one of the papers I have in the mix
right now is a pattern language of the
brain
so here's my position and I think it's
fairly straightforward artificial in
general intelligence however we might
Define it is something that is
Generations away
any focus on the existential risks of
AGI is a dangerous distraction that
takes away Focus From the Clear and
Present risks of AI there was a paper in
the Washington Post yesterday let's all
calm down about ai's extension risk and
it said something very well looking
closer at AI systems Now versus ringing
our hands about a vague Apocalypse of
the future is not only more sensible it
puts humans in a stronger position to
prevent a catastrophic event from
happening in the first place
I am also not motivated by fear as with
all due respect you seem to be and many
of your fellow effective altruists I am
confident in the human spirit in the
resilience of the human Spirit the
general trajectory of human evolution
and a recognition that we are in fact
our co-evolving with our AIS
ten minute mentioned I'm working on a
documentary Computing The Human
Experience and that research has led me
to a number of interesting Avenues and I
sort of summarize it by saying the story
of computing is the story of humanity
and this is a story that's just
beginning and you and I and Tim and all
the others are in the midst of that
story but I think the most important
outcome of this story is that it this
journey is it compels us to ask what
does it mean to be human
thank you Tim
thank you very much Grady
um Connor your opening statement
thank you so much thank you so much
greedy as well that was a really great
opening statement you know uh uh really
lead your point pretty great
totally agree with you that I think we
have a lot of overlap here seems we also
have some pretty clear disagreements
here that I think are really interesting
and I look forward to just like
understanding your position better I you
know I want to pre-register that I
totally am open that I'm totally wrong
about this that I've gotten something
terrifically wrong that some part of my
model is miscalibrated there was Data I
didn't know about or whatever and so
anyone who can help you know you know
show potentially other sides that I
would have missed and so on is I'm very
thankful for that and I you know really
really appreciate that so of course
though at the moment I do have somehow
disagreement for one I don't consider
myself an effective altruist but even so
I'm friends with many of them
um and but that aside
um it is true that I am very concerned
about existential risk I don't consider
this to be a thing that is far away
um I don't like the script personally
dislike the description of you know
acting out of fear because I feel like
this is just submissive this is uh it's
talking about the psychology right other
than the object so like you could say
you know someone who is concerned about
nuclear war during the Cold War is
acting out of fear and I think this
would be a fair thing to say but I feel
like it is at least in my perspective
kind of unfair towards what is going on
the actual question is is there nuclear
war and then you know what any
individual person you know maybe the
person who's concerned about is neurotic
Maybe not maybe they are fearful maybe
not I don't think this is something I'm
super interested in so what I'm
interested in is so you brought up a few
points that I think are really
interesting and I'd like to talk about a
little bit I like to get into more
I'm very curious to hear more about you
saying how you for example say language
models cannot do any kind of reasoning I
really like to dig into that and
understand more why you believe this
um and also like what you mean by the
word reasoning
um I tend to take very pragmatic
approaches to things so like I consider
myself naive in a sense I don't know how
human intelligence works I have some
guesses I know you know the latest
Neuroscience models I read friston and
stuff like this I know many of these
things but I am I try to be agnostic is
that I don't know why if you take a
chimp brain and you scale it up by a
factor of three you suddenly get a
species that goes to the moon
chimps don't go to the moon and you know
if you shrink down the chain brain by a
factor of three you still get a monkey
you scale it up chimp size still a
monkey scale it up to human size
suddenly you have a technological
species that goes to the moon I don't
know why that happened I have a bunch of
ideas and a bunch of theories but I
don't claim any of these are good or
that they're very predictive so in a
similar sense
I didn't predict gpt3 would happen I
didn't predict gpt4 would happen I
wasn't capable my theories didn't tell
me oh it will be able to do these tasks
but it won't scale Beyond this point so
after having myself been surprised again
and again that you know oh you just take
a gpt2 you put more compute in it and
suddenly can do these other tasks which
you may not think is reasoning we could
talk about that
given that I don't know why this
happened
I don't know where the limits are and I
think there is a plausible story to be
told that things can continue at this
rate and then you could get intelligent
systems not just feed forward language
models to be clear I'm not concerned
about you know gpd4 doing a forward pass
or gb5 or six not what I'm concerned
about I'm concerned about is far more
systems because someone's like Auto GPT
if you're familiar with that so like
systems that recursively call language
models have kind of like system one
reasoning systems so you know kataman's
reasoning uh hierarchy he's something he
calls like system one system two or type
one processing and type 2 processing and
you can type one process things like
intuitive pattern fuzzy pattern matching
kind of stuff like you know gut reaction
stuff and condom undescribe system two
so like reasoning like logical reasoning
as uh chaining system one reasoning
serially plus memory
this seems to be something that you can
do and that you can build and people are
starting to build on top of these kinds
of systems I don't know if this will
scale to AGI but I don't have a reason
why not it seems like it would and so as
a precautionary principle when you know
Stakes are this High I think it is very
prudent to take these six very seriously
and I also want to push this as a final
point I want to push a little bit
against the thing that that is a
destruction I think this is definitely
partially true people can overreact to
things they can hyper focus on things
and lose track of other things that
matters this is a risk this is a problem
I agree but I think a lot of the
problems that we see today are on the
same Spectrum as the problems that I'm
concerned about problems such as you
know hallucinations honesty
interpretability you know transparency
of current AI models I think are as much
a current risk as they are a part of the
larger story if someone produced a large
language model that never hallucinates I
would consider this extremely fantastic
progress on the problems I care about
personally so I'll leave it at that for
the moment
cannot hear you Grady unfortunately
I muted so thank you Connor that was
awesome Ken can we just do a back and
forth here because I've got some
questions to Connor and I oh yeah on
here uh I took a bunch of notes Here uh
you mentioned Kahneman fascinating you
should mention him because he's actually
on a project I'm on uh there's an effort
uh let's see it's called uh what do we
what's the name of this project I forget
our code name uh it's led by Francesca
Rossi inside IBM she also happens to be
our representative to the partnership
for AI and she's the current president
of the triple AI uh we're actually on a
project with him on that very topic of
system one system two now I disagree
with him on some of his Concepts because
I view it as not a dichotomous dichotomy
but it's more of a spectrum of system
one and system two indeed in the work we
did on self this is the architecture for
the Hal like thing
um we were very much influenced by the
work of first Minsky and his ideas of
society of mine fine together with the
ideas of Rodney Brooks his assumption
architecture and lastly uh that of
hofstetter and his ideas of strange
Loops so thank you I'm delighted that
you're familiar with kinderman's work
and that's cool
uh bear with me as I look through some
of my notes Here you mentioned the issue
fear was it an insult I'm just trying to
reflect upon what are the things I've
heard you say uh for example there was
one time on Twitter you said I do not
expect we'll get out of the century
alive and that's not a particularly
positive kind of thing
Conor I can guarantee that neither you
nor Ryan or Tim are going to get out of
the century alive uh current demographic
suggests you're what 20 something you're
not going to make it to 20 20 2100 sorry
about that I'm not either so hey it's
true I think you were meaning in the
sense of AI but I don't think that's
going to happen
uh let's see I want to dive into the
architecture thing in a moment because
that's my sweet spot but let me touch
upon a few other things
never meant to characterize you as an AI
person because I don't know you correct
me if I'm wrong though your company is
partly funded by Sam Bell Sam Beckman
Friedman who is noted E.I EA guy correct
he gave us a 50 000 Angel investment
after someone told him that we exist yes
okay well he's he's a strange man and we
could spend hours about he's a strange
man and I hope he you know uh gets the
Justice he deserves there you go oh okay
good we also have common ground great
great great
cryptocurrency is another topic we could
spend an hour on let's talk about war
for a moment because I in in reading
some of your other and watching some of
your other presentations this was a
focus upon you because here's an
interesting question let's suppose AGI
is real
how would it in fact destroy us because
Extinction is a pretty high high bar if
you think about it I mean we've we in
the world have gone through some really
nasty times there was in 7300 BCE there
was a huge volcanic operation uh
eruption that that kind of wiped out
much of humanity there was the black
death in 1347 in 536 which some
historians say was the worst year ever
to live there was widespread starvation
and yet we made it through all that so
Extinction is a really high bar and
that's why I don't think we're near
extension we could have some nasty times
but the most nasty time that I've heard
you or anybody talk about is this thread
that says we get an AGI that takes over
the world and launches nuclear missiles
so that seems to be the most obvious
path for how we could get an existential
the existential risk was that a fair
statement I mean what other paths are
there are from an AGI to wipe us out so
I actually consider the scenario kind of
unlikely I think it's like a nicely
visceral one like a lower bound like
you're like well if it could hack
everything it can manipulate humans at
the very least you know I could send a
few nukes off and you know trigger the
Russians to retaliate or something like
that but this is not a scenario I think
it's like likely because you know then
the AI nukes its own stuff that seems
like kind of a waste I mean maybe
you dwelled upon that in your last
conversation with Joshua Bach that was
that was sort of your thread so
enlighten me what is a more probable
path
a more probable path is something more
along the lines of so the way to think
about it is more the way I like to think
about it is if let's assume me and a
hundred sociopathic John Von Newmans
that never sleep and have no moral
qualms whatsoever wanted to achieve
something say we want them we're talking
Congress in other words right uh 100. do
you think that you think Congress is as
competent as Jon Von Newman everyone no
no no probably not but maybe the
psychopath side we might have common
ground there I don't know maybe but yeah
most psychopaths are not very
intelligent I think this is a pretty
important part of my model that we
should talk if you want to talk about
like a good question is why don't
terrorists cause more harm I think this
is a good question my answer is I think
most people most terrorists most people
who become terrorists are not very smart
and they're not competent they're not
organized they're not uh they're not
good at coordination they're not uh you
know I expect if every terrorist alive
woke up tomorrow and is 10 times as
smart as Jon Von Newman and had billions
of dollars I think that would be really
bad
I'm not you know
like let's Okay so let's continue down
your scenario 100 evil Von neumans
living in volcanic layers exactly so we
have evil John Von Newman's right
hundred of them or a thousand if they
never sleep they've read every book ever
written they're Immortal
Etc they're extremely charismatic
they've they you know are super good at
convincing people these are all things
that you know pretty straightforwardly
accessible from current technology at
least in my opinion but you know let's
set that aside
so assuming you had this
how far could you go like what could you
do with this I think this is a pretty
important part in my part of the model
it seems pretty obvious that you could
take control of almost anything you
could develop extremely powerful
technology you could you know charm or
bribe your way into you know control of
a nation-state or whatever and this is
still with human level intelligence
maybe you disagree with this
um
what I expect will happen
is we won't have something which is just
Jon Von Newman it's going to be way
smarter than that so these systems will
you know it basically very quickly be
capable of replacing most or all of the
economy so these systems will be cheaper
and more effective at Labor that humans
add everything so they will be able to
replace humans in all forms of Labor
they will be able to replace
that part of the economy if they wanted
to so they will be able to exert you
know trillions of dollars of you know
economic activity very quickly
and
look at what humans have done for the
planet
look at what we've done with trillions
of dollars of economic impact and this
is without all of us being a hive mind
you know John Von Neumann Collective I
expect if we were a hive minded Jon Von
Neumann Collective with trillions of
dollars worth of economic pressure and
control over the environment and
potential technology that is very
Advanced so say you run these John Von
neumans that you know
a thousand X speed you know you get a
thousand times chips that you know
switch much faster and you run them a
thousand X human speed you know human
reaction time is like 100 milliseconds
or something you could probably get like
you know 10 to a thousand X faster than
that assuming you could well now you
know for every day that passes they can
do you know a year or two of
technological research
so imagine you have 100 John Von
Newman's that are now working at a pace
of two years per day
you developing new weapons Technologies
strategies
um you know economic plans you know
every time they're trying to convince
someone they can think for subjective
months about what their next answer is
going to be before they answer
and then
you these generalized capabilities
generalize you have these systems that
will develop very fast technology they
will you know take over the labor force
I mean human will allow them to do this
as part of my Mainline model my Mainline
model is this won't be some weird you
know oh no something broke out of a box
I think people will wanted them to take
over things people will give them
control over more and more companies
they will give them control over a
larger and larger aspects of the economy
they'll be very persuasive they'll be
seductive you know people fall in love
with these AIS they'll be incredible
they'll be much more attractive to like
on like a social level than like any
human can be
um they will be they will be able to you
know collect blackmail material on
people that way very very easily
um and then I think yeah if you're at
that point where you control basically
the entire economy you have technology
which is potentially a hundred years or
hundreds of years Advanced you have
um social control over Most states or
Community I expect at that point if you
are annoyed that humans are around you
could just make them go away and I don't
you know there's various techniques they
might use to do this but the same way
that humans if we wanted to could make
chimps go away like if all of humanity
if all of humanity aside you know what
chimps gone let's get rid of them I
think we could do that and similarly I
think in such such an AGI system at this
point we'll think well you know these
humans being all around my circuit
boards you know they're kind of
inefficient they need a lot of food they
have nukes they might destroy some of my
nice data centers lots of big hassle
isn't it so maybe just you know invent
the human version of bug spray and you
know then it's just kind of over
I don't know if it's exactly that's
what's gonna happen but like you know
you know it seems like at least
plausible to me that something like this
could occur cool well let's talk about I
took a number of notes again so thank
you for that observation and and to
conclude what I heard you say is that
war is the least likely path for an AGI
representing existential risk the more
likely path is a some Cobble of Von
Neumann like folks who use agis as the
mechanism for them to take control so to
be clear the Von neumans were agis in
this case I do expect I don't agree well
yeah okay so so AGI Von neumannish agis
are the ones that take over yeah
something like this that's your path
okay cool yeah let's talk about war for
a moment I'm happy you dismiss it I
would hardly recommend that in your
discourses with others you stop talking
about it because that seems to be the
one you migrate to because it's the
fearful one as for myself I was involved
in the architecture of sybers which is
our early warning infrared system for
nuclear launches I involved in uh most
recently the
a project that let's just basically say
it's one of the three legs of the Triad
that evolves everything from the
president's briefcase down to the men
and women the silos you're not going to
assure you that you are correct that the
kind of scenario is excruciatingly rare
and impossible in the presence of an AI
in that Loop it ain't going to happen in
my lifetime or your lifetime or the next
set of folks so I would urge you to pull
that out of your repertoire because it's
a bit of a distraction device yeah
you're let's talk about your specific
one oh you might want to you might want
to look up a little do a little research
on what are called permissive action
links
which are some of the mechanisms you
mentioned one of your talks about there
were two or three incidents called work
of you know sort of we were on the break
of it you're kind of right but there's a
lot of stuff that's happened and things
like those Pals
IES
we're losing your audio a tiny bit I'm
not sure whether it's your connection
oh no worries I'm sorry I was I'll move
my hand about here because I'm kind of
making my own little little uh horn
correct my voice this is low Tech here
let's talk about now your particular
scenario
uh okay so I think I understand it it's
let's what should we call this well
actually now
it reminds me a lot of the uh of the
episodes of the series with Kiefer
Sutherland the rabbit hole because there
was a guy that had an AGI at his
disposal that was kind of taking over
the world so you might want to take a
look at it because it eerily parallels
what you described and again it's it's
why I sort of view you were you were a
little bit more you're not a little bit
you're a lot more driven by fear than I
am because that's kind of a fearful
scenario and I don't think it's going to
happen I don't think it's going to
happen for the following sets of reasons
first it's a systems engineering problem
you talk about these AIS that are out
there in the world taking over resources
and the like problem is you're looking
at it from a zero-sum game kind of
perspective I'm a systems engineer and
if you look at it in perspective of go
look at
um at Simon's artificials science is the
artificial great book and it'll tell you
a few things in that space go read de
Gall systematics you'll see some other
things in that regard and then lastly
there's a great by oh what's the guy's
name
oh can't remember it but it'll come
to me I'll run a background process here
in a bit he was a NASA scientist so the
problem is the systems problem did you
say for example we might get together
and say we're going to destroy all
chimps I could guarantee you there's
going to be a bunch of chimp lovers in
the world who are going to push back
against that and they're going to add
forces that say that's not going to
happen even to a greater degree I think
you're going to see that in the systemic
level you're speaking about at this
level of taking over all of all of
economic labor
this is the reality of civilization that
you can fool some of the citizens some
of the time but not all the citizens all
the time and so the system theory that I
have that I know about tells me it is
the resilience of civilization as such
it is highly improbable such a thing
would happen furthermore those AIS it's
going to take a long time for them to
get all the resources the production
that they can control you know mind this
for me build these tips for me and we
live in a world that is sufficiently
disconnected and distributed that those
pieces just don't fit together and so
unless we're in a vastly different
society which is not going to happen in
your lifetime or the next general
Generations we're not going to deal with
that interconnection so here's here's
rid of my premise a super intelligence
like you described that would have even
the faintest potential of taking us over
and leading to existential risk would
also have to be super embodied in the
world and the we humans are going to
push back against this so that's that's
the fundamental problem I have there the
second is you make the assumption that
they're not going to want us
and you don't know that that's the worst
possible wager you're making you're
making a little bit of a Pascal's wager
here saying just in case they hate us
I'm going to do this but I think that is
also excruciatingly slow so you put
those minuscule probabilities upon
minuscule probabilities it again gets us
to something that I'm not going to think
about during my day and it's a
distraction
okay thanks yeah thank you so much for
making the points very clear those are
some really uh care points I think your
model is quite sensible actually I I
understand where you're coming from here
uh I I yeah it's like seems quite
reasonable to me I of course disagree uh
so and I think I can well I want to
tell me why you disagree yeah I think I
can locate the cruxes or at least an
attempt to locate some of the cruxes so
on the first question I feel like the
pushback is saying is uh this is how I
heard it you're saying something such as
that if we were seeing systems they're
moving towards dangerous regimes of
embodiment autonomy Etc that Humanity
would react that Humanity would
coordinate that we would stop this from
happening is that does that sound like
really reasonable yes it in fact it goes
back to Weiner's ideas of homeostasis in
that regard yes and the evidence for
that is looking back at those you know
catastrophic events we have managed to
Rally together
as humans so yes you heard me correctly
great so so I I think this is a great
point and I really hope you're right
about this this is something that I
absolutely hope you're correct about and
I think you might be right about this so
assuming you are correct about this
wouldn't you expect homeostatic
processes such as you know young guys
with long hair going to the government
and calling for regulation for what they
see as things moving into dangerous
regimes wouldn't this potentially be
part of such a homostatic system
now you're acting out of fear again
because that's exactly what that's
exactly what Sam and others are doing
and of course remember that Sam has his
own particular agenda and you saw the
report in the last 24 hours that
apparently Not only was he making the
Rounds Around the World saying oh trust
me but at the same time he was looking
for for uh for he was lobbying Congress
for a particular rule we were very
favorable to uh open AI well again this
is why we have we why we have economic
systems that pushed back against folks
such as him Sam's Sam's a charismatic
guy I think he's flawed as a human in
many ways and I really push back against
a lot of the things that open AI is
doing but again I yes I would say the
homeostatic mechanisms of human life as
well as the economic systems we have
will indeed push back doesn't mean
there's not going to be human cost along
the way but in terms of catastrophic
failure
unlikely to happen
okay
um
I'll give you an analogy here here's the
analogy I forgot to mention
you believe in the laws of physics
yes I think we have common ground I
think we also have common ground that
any AGI would be subject to the laws of
physics that there's no magical thing
happening here you're sitting in a room
I can't quite tell what it is it looks
like a white room of some sort so am I
the laws of physics tell me that it is
possible
for all the oxygen in this room to
suddenly move to a corner and thereby
you and I would both be affixiated it is
possible but it is excruciatingly
improbable it would be doing so because
there are very actions of me waving my
hand about are creating brownie emotions
and other emotions that are pushing back
against it
I think what you're describing is
exactly like that auction scenario it is
possible that this might happen but the
improbability is so vastly high I'm not
gonna think
so this is great this is actually an
actual Crux I think we can directly
point to it seems you're modeling uh
these kinds of scenarios as more of a
normal distribution well I modeled them
as a fat tail distribution so I model
stuff like Wars like casualties and Wars
I think are best described by fat tail
distributions like about that where
outliers dominate the expected value so
like you know a you have you know a lot
of little Wars where very few people die
and then you have a World War II where
millions of people die I think a lot of
events uh technological events many
historical events Wars uh economic
things many things are well modeled by
you know economic shocks financial
crisis Etc are better modeled as uh
Black Swan events as like um fat tail
distributions where you have these
extreme outliers which dominate the
expected value well it seems you think
of more of like a Brownian more like a
gaussian kind of distribution of events
does it seem like a sensible Crux
well let me understand what you just
said and by the way I want to make sure
we spend time on non-philosophical
things let's talk about architecture in
a bit so if it's okay with you let's
spend a few minutes on this and let's
get down to the technology because I
would like to before we switch also
respond to the second point you made
earlier
happy to do that happy to do that so so
let me here let me play back what I
heard you say
um you are you view War for example as a
long fat tail event correct yes and I
think at the beginning you said you were
more worried about fat tail events than
other things tell me tell me fat tail
versus Black Swan events I'm trying
again same thing okay yeah I I have you
at a disadvantage then let's talk about
war I'm a graduate of the Air Force
Academy one of our military academies I
studied War I studied models of War
they're not fat tail events they're
they're normal distribution kind of
things so we can talk about that later
so let's let's again take War out of the
picture here it's a lot more normal than
you might realize okay you're worried
about long fat tail long uh Black Swan
events in this case being the the AGI I
think give me an example of a fat tail
Black Swan event that's happened in the
last Thousand Years
the I mean the 2008 financial crisis the
black plague
um you know the uh smallpox play kidding
America
um you know things of the kind the
Industrial Revolution
none of which were existential events
killing all of us I agree there were
events right there were events that
disturbed us but again the resilience of
us brought us back which is again my
point by saying you may have these
events yeah okay so we can agree upon
that but there's an important Point here
you have to be careful you can't update
on the non-existence of existential
events because if existential events had
happened you would not be here to update
on them right which is also why I don't
worry about them because if they happen
and I have no control over them it's not
going to matter at all so I'm going to
go live my life what can you do today at
this moment Conor I'm seeing reading
your body language what can you do today
at this moment to avoid that Black Swan
event that you're so worried about what
would you do today well probably the
things I'm doing right now I you know
I work on the technical problem of
alignment I think I don't know what that
means I don't know what that means it'll
enlighten me so this is actually a great
way to respond to the second point you
raised earlier we talked about why would
I expect an AGI to not be friendly to
humanity I think this is a great
question and so my
I don't expect AGI to be unfriendly what
I expect is expected to not care I
expect my we could talk about technicals
now if you also want to my expectation
is by default intelligence is orthogonal
to values you could have very
intelligent systems that have very
different values you can have very smart
people who are very kind and very loving
and you can have very smart people who
are complete sociopaths and like killing
people these are orthogonal to
intelligence you could have intelligence
systems that has any particular goal in
any particular like you know and so if
we don't and I think these are brutal so
like you know Evolution tried very very
hard to give humans the value of you
know improving our genetic fitness but
instead we develop condoms because the
alignment to the true value is quite bad
so humans actually started liking sex
not reproduction
this is a failure and uh you know quote
unquote failure I expect some more
things will happen with AIS we'll train
them for example to maximize human you
know you know thumbs up or whatever or
approval of some kind and then the AIS
will you know learn some weird proxy you
know that humans like these kinds of
patterns or they like to you know not
never be offended they or they like to
you know be smile a lot and oh they like
heroin cool or like whatever right and
then they will maximize these weird
proxies rather than the actual thing we
want them to optimize for and I expect
by default if you maximize
something
it's generally useful to gain power it's
useful to have resources it's useful to
have intelligence have control of your
environment physical resources energy
you know Etc and you don't want people
interrupting you so if we build some AGI
system with some proxy value and we try
to shut it off it will by default
prevent us from doing so because it will
simply coldly reason if I am shut oops
sorry about that if I am shut down
then I cannot
further you know achieve the goal
whatever this goal is that I'm trying to
achieve currently so I think this is a
large degree a technical problem it's
just like we should understand
intelligence and we should understand
goals better like what our goals how are
they encoded how can we think about
optimizers like why how does the you
know the brain do it how can we build
systems where we can like understand how
they will execute on
goals or values or so on I'm not saying
I have a solution I absolutely do not
it's this you know very complex you know
field of research but I think this is
quite important and I expect by default
these things just don't go well and we
you know me or someone you know ideally
I wish that you know all the string
theorists in the world all the greatest
mathematicians and computer scientists
would all go work on you know how to
encode goals into comp into powerful
optimizers and you know I kick back and
you know let the smart people do it but
um I'm quite concerned that a lot of
people seem to not be working on this
problem
you mentioned that uh you know we
discovered that we like sex is for fun I
think you astonishingly under
misunderstand Evolution look at bonobos
I think the idea of sex being fun is
something that has existed in all of all
of uh all of life so it's not something
that suddenly happened as we got
together and said oh sex is cool so
let's move on now yeah sorry that's not
what I was intending to say what I was
interesting to say is more Evolution the
algorithm the like you know God's eye
view is you know optimizing for a metric
that's something like inclusive genetic
fitness you know not literally but like
something like that and to do this put
some proxy in the brain we're like you
know like ah these shapes you know kind
of indicate a female or a male of your
species
you know increase reward if you're near
them increase reward if you do this
whatever and this circuit that got put
into the brain doesn't actually
calculate inclusive genetic fitness
because how would it you know the brain
can't calculate its own includes genetic
Fields it calculates some proxy value so
it correlates with inclusive genetic
fitness and in the ancestral environment
that might be fine but then as we got
more powerful we got more control over
our environment now that we understand
inclusiveness Fitness like you and me we
understand the concept of inclusive to
Fitness but at least I don't know how
you feel about it but like I don't
particularly care about it very much
like I know Evolution wants me to have
the maximum number of options possible
but I don't really care I don't really I
don't optimize for that I could I
understand it and I expect this is how
AGI will be as well it will understand
human values it will know what they are
it just won't care
well it Evolution doesn't want more
offspring Evolution doesn't want
anything you're anthropomorphizing it it
has forces that lead to that particular
Behavior so I'll go along with that uh
your your your description of this one
AGI that was you know pushing back
against us reminds me dangerously of the
the what I think is a silly analogy that
came from the guy who wrote super
intelligence by the way I did a TED talk
because of his paper his book pushing
back against it uh go go Google Ted and
booch and you'll see it but it's like
the paper clip thing and you said oh you
know they're going to optimize for this
but it got back to my earlier point that
only works at that intelligence is super
embodied because if they have no Direct
Control that cannot be intervened uh to
do that that's not going to happen then
I'm going to quote something that Benny
Joe said he wrote an article
um uh how Rogue a guys may arise because
he said something that resonates I think
with you a super intelligent AI system
that is autonomous and goal directed
would be a potentially Rogue AI if its
goals do not strictly include the
well-being of humanity and the biosphere
I.E it is not sufficiently aligned with
human rights and values to guarantee
acting in ways to avoid harm to humanity
let's suddenly make me Chinese whose
value are we talking about Connor yours
or mine my value as in pushing the state
is going to be very different than yours
who gets to decide Connor so this is a
very important question it is a separate
question though from the question we're
talking about before I just want to
postmark that we're changing it's it's
related because you said we need to have
you know we need to choose values and if
we're going to choose values it's going
to be whose values sure but there's two
questions the one question is how do you
do values at all like the technical
question of how do you put any values
into a system at all there's a second
question of what values I think these
are both in very very important
questions and they're worth addressing I
just want to make clear that these are
two different questions I I accept there
we'll separate those I'll go along with
that cool yeah so yes this is a very
important question and this is a
question which is not a question for
science this is a question for
philosophy and politics more so than for
anything else I would like to go to a
world where this is the most impre that
this is a question we can and should
answer as a civilization I want to get
to the world where the problem is not
that a random system that we cannot
troll it just blows up everything to get
to a point where like we have a vessel
which can contain values which we can
use for good which people can bargain
about their values with where moral
philosophers can you know reason about
moral uncertainty or whatever and can
then put it into the system this is a
world I would like to get to I do not
think this is a world we get to by
default so people have different values
this is correct and we could talk about
my personal views on like moral
reflectivity and that I actually expect
that not all but a very large percentage
of human values are quite Universal I
think there's some things that are you
know me and you know the Chinese
Communist Party would agree on there's
some things we would not agree on but I
think there's many things that we would
actually agree on I expect by bulk I
would agree on things you know we like
you know pain is bad you know humans
good aren't good you might have
different tastes in art and they might
have some truly awful beliefs about some
kind of authoritarian and things
but
I'm not going to claim that I can solve
this on behalf of humanity but I also
don't think this is a problem you can
ignore this is not something you're you
can just like pull out as a trump card
and be like well you can't solve it I'm
like yes that's true I can't solve it
but someday someone will either if these
values will be rolled at random or
someone puts them in by force or we find
some other bosses but one way or another
eventually someone builds AGI it will
have some values
okay fair enough so at the beginning I
wanted I said I don't want to talk about
philosophy and yet we've been spending
most of our time on that yeah sorry
about that no that's fine that's fine uh
we'll leave it to the philosophers let
me offer the following goal post I made
the statement earlier large language
models do not reason and indeed are
architecturally incapable of reasoning
that's the goal I'm going to set a
little bit further down the road here
let's walk along that goal because I
want to move to some more technical
things along the way here
because it it leads us to questions of
how does the mind bring about values
which I think is relevant to what you
were describing there and therefore how
would I embody those values any kind of
thing is that is that fear that we pivot
to that at this moment yeah I would love
to I'd love to hear your your vote
either great so let's talk about the
nature of the mind for a moment
I think there's a spectrum which is why
kaneman and I disagree in this regard it
is a spectrum of this and if we look at
the nature of any intelligence
and first off it's a terrible word I
don't know what you can call it I think
there's a spectrum that goes from
intelligence which is we'll talk about
in a moment to Notions of Consciousness
to then sentience
and then there's a whole model of things
among them so let's talk about each of
those
10 tians is largely one of having
a uh a subjective experience I think
that's a fair statement and that's why
embodiment becomes an important factor
for me because I can't really have a
rich subjective experience if all I'm
dealing with just text and that's
another topic undo itself can I have
sentience Consciousness just by seeing
texts and I think no but it's probably a
matter of richness anyway that's what
sentience means for me it's having a
subjective experience
consciousness
and self-consciousness are related and
they relate to what hofstetter would
speak of as strange Loops I don't think
the problem of Consciousness is that
hard at all but it's a matter of if you
will an allusion to use Dennis terms
that we see agents seeing other agents
and therefore infer their existence from
it that's I believe what comes from it
but what comes from Consciousness is
that that entity therefore has theories
theories of the world theories of itself
and theories of others and that becomes
important we talk about intelligence so
we know that those theories exist at
that point of Consciousness but another
thing that comes with Consciousness is
the sense of agency because now there is
a self that can act in its own
particular interests and then there is
also a degree of self-learning because a
self can then say there are things that
are not selves and therefore I would am
curious about them which is a value and
therefore I can have some self-motivated
learning so that's cool now we're on the
problem of intelligence which is where
it becomes very nasty and hard I really
like Francois chalets paper on the
measure of intelligence great one if
you've not any of you seen that or not
but it's it's good and I think from that
you and I can conclude there are
intelligences other than the lens of
humanity we're on that so let's break
apart intelligence for a moment
there's reasoning
there's causality there's Common Sense
there's understanding those seem to be
some of the components of intelligence
so far so good
uh it makes sense to me so I don't know
what those components mean which is
right I'm going to go down to the next
the next level of that let's talk about
reasoning because that's the easiest one
first there are some easy ones inductive
deductive and abductive reasoning do you
know what I mean by abductive reasoning
explain it for the audience abductive
reasoning is Theory building which says
uh oh I see this house on fire I see
smoke around this house I see Flames I
see fire engines therefore I will build
a theory that the house is on fire so
abductive reasoning is one of theory
making so it says I propose a theory and
I can then act upon that theory that's
abductive reasoning
we know how to do inductive and
deductive reasoning pretty well in our
machines if you go back to uh Newell and
Simon's work and their General Problem
Solver that's the stuff they were doing
in fact if you look at I'm going to
throw on my architecture hat if you look
at the evolution of architectures in AI
that Community has been approaching that
problem in many different ways the first
one was through formal mathematics that
was the Simon and Newell realm of things
then there was the work with feigenbaum
it had a lovely chance to work with Ed
some years ago on knowledge Engineering
Systems and now we're in the realm of of
we throw piles of examples and and train
and AI on it uh trade trainer neural
network so totally different kinds of
architectures and we know in each of
those there's some degree of reasoning
taking place
but here's why I say that large language
models do not reason and indeed are
architecturally incapable of reasoning
there is a paper I'll point you to
toward reasoning in large language
models by ye Hong who did a survey of
reasoning in large language models and
he concludes it is not yet clear to what
extent llms are capable of reasoning now
this is I think a profound observation
because they've been out in the wild for
a while literally millions of people
have used them and yet we still have no
compelling evidence as to what reasoning
might mean so that that's very telling
for me it might mean maybe we don't know
what reasoning is and understanding may
be the case but let's look at it from an
architecture point of view
you study the architecture of gpt2 I've
said of the architecture of a lot of a
lot of large language models we built
some of Romans and the like they are
stochastic parents that's not a
condemnation that's a reality of them
they are next word predictors and there
is nothing architecturally in them
whereby they build models of the world
in which they are looking at and can
infer upon those models I'll stop at a
moment by saying that leads me to the
notion of understanding
because they're very very related I can
reason about something and you might say
oh that person is smart but they don't
understand because and I'll read you
something here from from what ning said
he said that to the extent that large
language models is building a worth
model it's conveying learning some
understanding of the world but that's
this current view so Andrew is saying
because it's building a world model it
has some understanding it's not really
building a role model uh Hanton says we
believe the process of creating features
of embeddings and the interactions
between features is understanding but
he's looking at it from the bottom up I
have a lot of problems at that point of
view here's the way I view it
understanding involves the creation of a
theory that can be tested and one
consequence of that position is it
requires an understanding my recursion
is intentional of the limits of that
theory by the way this is the key to
moving to your so-called agis because it
gives us the lever in which we can look
at things we don't know and self learn
from it so by that sense this is why I
say large language models are
architecturally incapable they are not
model builders in that regard and they
don't have models that they can test
against there's another great paper the
limits of Transformers on composability
that goes into one particular Niche
place of that that talks about how
Transformers simply are incapable of
building those kinds of world models so
there's significant evidence
I'll stop there understanding reasoning
causality I haven't even talked about
causality common sense we'll talk about
those later but that's I'll stop there
and shut up for a minute let you react
yeah I think there is definitely a lot
of sensible things to this I guess I am
just less confident than you I'm not
even sure I disagree I'm just way less
confident that I understand what
language models are actually doing
internally
um for example you know there's been
just purely mathematically you can model
the forward pass through an attention
layer as doing a step of gradient
descent in a you know on-the-fly
constructed space this is a general
operation like this is just
mathematically the case this is they're
just equivalent so you can by during
inference during you know a few shot
learning these models can build
temporary representations and do
gradient descent do reasoning move
through these spaces pure leader in the
forward pass this is just a thing that
can be done I'm not saying this is
reasoning I'm doing this is things that
can be done they can they can build
spaces that you can put probes into that
you can you can do operations on whether
that's relevant you know powerful enough
you know it's another question
um and so I don't claim to know exactly
what these models are really doing and
how it really works but I think
potentially something worth
um teasing apart here is
um
the sense of like a single forward pass
like a GPT is raw State GPT plus the
sampling Loop this is technically not a
neural network anymore once you actually
do the sampling step of like actually
collapsing into new tokens and feeding
it back your system is completely out of
distribution the gbt models are never
trained on to complete their own
sentences this is not how they're
trained they're trained with feature
forcing so this is already out of
distribution Behavior this is already
something they're not trained to do
they're not trained to have predict a
token and then feed it back in this is
not how we actually train them we train
them on Raw data
um and then there's the question of you
know GP you know language model uh
training Loop and SGD
so I think you might be correct that
maybe language models can't build models
maybe but I think SGD can
um I think sorry you're about it if in
case you reacting to that
now you're talking about the beauty of
strange Loops as hofstitter speaks about
and I am a strange Lucas with one book
in that sense and so scale brings us
amazing things Luke's bring us amazing
things you're describing that but
remember that this is within a closed
system large language models are are
working across
multi-dimensional latent spaces and all
that you're still doing even in those
Loops is still navigating about those
those latent spaces interesting ways it
reminds me of alphago and you may recall
the quote from one of the uh the humans
that played against it and he was just
totally humiliated by and he said I have
seen the face of God and he claimed that
it's creative I think you're seeing a
similar phenomena here and I think of it
this way in the game of Go it is one
that is clearly has more State spaces
than we humans can comprehend and even
our machines can comprehend history and
tradition and training have led us
humans to walk across specific mountains
and Valley paths quite often and what
alphago did was said I don't care about
that I am not bound by tradition I'm
just going to look across the latent
space and it led me to these places
which from a human was astonishing
because it was outside the boundary of
our tradition to the all AI it was not
because it was just part of it that I
believe is the same thing that's
happening inside these large language
models so I'm I'm happy that you accept
that you may not know you're agnostic in
that sense I certainly can't claim to
know no one knows either but I do know
that from how it is built that there are
obviously vast limitations and
furthermore it is still a closed system
for that matter I can't prove that
you're conscious I have a pretty good
feel about it you can't prove that I am
or I might just be a really good new
version of chat GPT but I can probe you
from the outside and that's where the
understanding experiments come in and
we've seen that like in the paper I
mentioned uh the paper by Jay Hong that
was asking those kind of questions you
can probe a model and you'll realize
no it's it's not doing any understanding
and certainly not any deep understanding
so I think where we could both say is we
can both agree
I'm more suspect of it than you are but
I think we can both agree that there is
a lot of work to be done in that space
right now
I definitely agree if that gbt three or
four are not AGI they're they're they
can't you know autonomously act they
can't do the kind of reasoning you're
describing it's I think they can do pro
I I suspect they could do more of it
than you suspect they can but I think
this is a spectrum I think your position
here is not unreasonable I you know
personally think differently but I think
this is a reasonable position to hold
and I might be wrong about this I might
be fooled in many sense I don't think I
am I've used these things quite
extensively and they can do some pretty
impressive things and I also come from
this from a bit of a neuroscience
perspective so you know I'm a best
amateur obviously so I of course defer
to True neuroscientists here but as an
amateur neuroscientist who you know
reads his predictive processing and
first and call fristin and stuff
this is my understanding this describing
of like you know moving through energy
Landscapes moving through spaces and
models and so on is the best current
theory of what we have what the brain
does yeah do you mind if I um
I'm going to talk about that I want to
talk about the Neuroscience in a minute
but go ahead Tim I was just going to say
I was going to prompt you you said that
intelligence is reasoning causality
common sense and understanding and and
you neglected to go into detail on
causality and common sense so let's just
do another 10 minutes or so and then
I've got some good audience questions to
ask you but so far this is great uh
carry on okay cool cool so super yeah
let's talk about let me split this word
let's talk about Neuroscience let's talk
about the others for a minute uh the
others are easy uh causality I'm a great
fan of Judea Pearl's work I mean go take
a look at his stuff and there are very
few people who have picked up on this
notion of causality as he's done I think
we're going to see some good stuff there
on the common sense side I mean you know
the work that psych did and Lynette did
which was really a Brute Force approach
to Common Sense there's a lot more work
to be done there but I think the key
goes back again to the ideas of models
that if I have some entity that has
models of the world models of self and
models of the others this is where I can
then do some some inferences some
predictability that I would then call
common sense I mean let's face it we as
humans at least the intelligence we know
the world real world is messy we are
used to ambiguity we are used to gaps
we're used to outright inconsistencies
in the day that we have and any
well-formed so-called AGI would have to
attend to that as well and so the whole
issue of imprecision we just don't quite
have well enough let's see where were we
um causality common sense and whatever
let's talk about Neuroscience for a
moment uh the notion of energy kind of
things I'm familiar with some of those
theories
um it's the case that uh uh Jan is down
that path as well and that makes sense
it goes back to the laws of physics but
remember brains don't do pro back
propagation there's a different kind of
plasticity happening in the brain uh you
say they do neuroscientists tell me the
brain does not do back propagation
you're correct but there is a very nice
paper about how predictive processing
can approximate to back prop radians to
like very high accuracy in very few
steps so I think you're correct that
they don't do back prop but I do think
they do great in descent
they they yes they probably do some form
of gradient descent but again that's I
think for projecting our own selves upon
it if you look at the biochemistry of
what happens at the level of synapses
it's not gradient descent it's a very
different thing you've got a whole set
of things going on with the limbic
system and uh and the activities of
dopamine and the like which impact it so
it's it's far more complex than that
I've got a book behind me on neural
circuitry and for literal decades you
know that Community has been trying to
understand that so be cautious of those
those outlier kind of papers so anyway
where are we where are we with
Neuroscience
um
uh I don't know where to go I'll stop
there I'm running out of words
I mean that's fair enough I mean I Do by
the way want to say that I'm also being
humble about the brain I think you're
like you're definitely right that I'm
wrong about this you're definitely
correct that I'm wrong it's definitely
not just gradient descent there's
definitely other things going on there
I'm familiar with like the you know
hypothalamus like literature and stuff
like this and neuropeptides and stuff
like this which is clearly not really
into samples clearly other algorithms at
play here yeah so totally agree with you
I just do like for the neuroscientists
so they don't totally hate me I'm
talking about the telencephalon
specifically I think to tell encephalon
is mostly doing the stuff in other parts
of the brain aren't but you know that
being said yeah I don't know I might be
wrong yeah
fan by the way I probably read it uh the
work by uh on intelligence by oh shoot
his name popped out of mine um Jeff Jeff
Hawkins yeah
he's doing some cool work there as well
yeah very cool
yeah all right okay I'll stop it there
Tim I'll turn it back over to you this
has been fun Congress so far yeah thank
you so much it's been really fun this
has been honestly this this is so much
better than than I thought it would be
the the energy between you guys is
amazing okay well we've got some fun
I've had with my clothes on all day so
all right all right okay uh well uh
great if you don't mind I'll go to you
first so one of the questions is
programming requires a high level of
abductive reasoning and I loved your
exposition of of abduction I I think of
it as one of the most important um
things in science actually and and I
kind of think of it as a as about
shaping the hypothesis space it's
something that you need to do before you
do inference which is a mapping process
but but anyway coming back to the
question
um this guy's a developer and he
wondered the extent to which it's an
existential risk for average developers
do you know do you think that these
models are doing even if it's mimicry a
reasonable amount of abduction
these these models being so gpt4 is is
it doing abduction to the extent where
it would replace Developers
oh okay
okay let's talk about the philosophical
part and then the pragmatic part of it
philosophical patterns from all I can
tell from the outside no Transformer
based large language model is doing
abductive reasoning is not happening but
let's talk about now things like
co-pilot and the like
um
I think of co-pilot like having a pair
programmer with a relatively green
naive developer who's read a lot of
books but not lived in the world much
so so they they oftentimes throw out
really interesting useful things like I
never heard of that because they've read
a lot more than I have but they also
spout they are they are
generators and therefore they
are useful in so far as I as the
programmer working with them have the
ability to discern between the two there
is a paper which I don't have in my
disposal right now that points out that
one of the findings of co-pilot is that
it actually generates far more security
leaks yeah than anything would so you
have to be careful about these kinds of
things so I think of it as it's faster
than going to stack Overflow that's what
it does for me right now
I think here's the path that I think
will be useful for us and it'll shut up
again I'm an architect and most of us in
the real world don't deal with
Greenfield systems they're in the most
fun they get a lot of the press but
reality is every time I write a line of
code it becomes Legacy in most of the
time I'm working in the context of
Legacy I'd really like to have an agent
that can absorb the entire code base I'm
working on and if I ask it questions
like if I jiggle this what happens
Nai could do that that's the trajectory
I see that going on it would be very
useful and by the way they're not going
to take over the world
they're just going to understand my code
base do you mind me just just very
quickly pressing on exactly why gpt4
doesn't do abduction now I I have an
intuition that abduction is related to
creativity and actually the first time
you generate some pros with gpt4 it
looks really good doesn't it and then
you read it again and it looks sclerotic
you read it again it looks even more
formulaic and sclerotic and it gets
worse and worse and worse so there's
something about a really good writer you
know they they have this creativity and
it's similar to abduction in the sense
that I'm selecting you know I'm carving
a space out of this infinite set of
possibilities that's my intuition why
gbt4 doesn't do it but what's your core
intuition
Umberto Rico one of my heroes has a book
called on beauty and another one called
on ugliness and he addresses the values
we have for what we consider to be
beautiful and ugly you have the same
kind of problem going on with creativity
how do I know what is creative or not
and there is Connor you and I and Tim
are unqualified to talk about this but
there's a set of artists out there and
there's a set of psychologists who have
deeply understood the nature of
creativity and I would urge you to get
one of them on here to talk about that
but my understanding of creativity and
I'll go down the path by saying I care
about this because there's a an episode
slash chapter in our documentary on Art
and creativity I've stumbled upon the
rabbit hole of computational creativity
where people are asking that very
question as to what creativity is and
from a human perspective it involves the
connection of disparate things that
otherwise the spirit things and the
discovery of of holes and paths that are
just out of the ordinary tradition so
that seems to be what creativity is is
it computational that's what that
Community is talking about right now so
is gpt4 capable of that
it's a stochastic period there's no it's
making connections we may not have seen
but there's nothing that I would
consider really creative in that sense
anyway I'll defer to the real experts in
creativity let's bring a poet artist on
here
yeah and I I share your love of
creativity I was a um an event to Oxford
University on creativity and I did about
six interviews and I've got five to
release so you can thanks look look
forward to that and Kenneth Stanley I
think is great on that as well but um
anyway to you Connor
um RM asks how can we calculate and
assign probabilities to existential
outcomes
the same way you predict any future
event poorly
it's uh you know there's the saying goes
it is very hard to make predictions
especially about the future ultimately
you cannot know but you know I'm pretty
willing to make bets you know if you
offered me you know 99 to 1 odds that
the sun you know will come up tomorrow
I'll be willing to take those odds I'd
probably even take 99.9 99.99 I don't
know I'm joking but
um it isn't easy it never is like you
know you can read like super forecasters
is like the classic book you should
definitely read when you if you actually
are interested about predicting the
future and like thinking about how
things work this is a book by um
Philip tetlock
which which looks into a really great
study where he studied uh both uh you
know top like uh intelligence analysts
and like crowd-sourced predictions for
like all kinds of things you know will
there be a war in this you know area
will you know this person get married
will this I don't know like lots of
random questions about the future it
posed in very very precise ways and they
found that uh most people are really
terrible at this pundits basically score
equally to chimpanzees on average
um but there are a people who can
perform very well which you would call
Super forecasters
um they can at least beat the noise on
many of them another thing is that this
is Acro averaged across a vast number of
domains So eventually you always regress
to the mean but it is possible to make
you know sensible predictions about
small things so
I think I have sensible models that I
you know can put vague you know
intuitions on about why I think future
events will happen the same way I can
make vague propositions about oh I think
my company will do well and you know
we'll raise money or something but like
you know maybe not I don't know maybe
something terrible will happen every
something great will happen sure but
still we make predictions this is very
normal I think a lot of times when
people put probabilities on something
what they're really doing is making a
statement about emotions something about
intuitions and I think this is fine I
think this is like not it's signal like
you know people's emotions and people's
models are signal you know if Grady
looked at my code and he said this is
awful and that he didn't explain why I
would still believe him you know it's
like uh he probably has a great
intuition about this even if he didn't
read it very carefully
um and similarly with extension risk
like when I say things like you know
probability of Doom of 90 or something
but I'm mostly trying to express by this
is not I calculated all the things and
did the like you know causal model
analysis if you want to read that I
think Carl Schumann did some of that at
open fill but I think it's not super
productive because you get into like you
know conjunctive hell
um I'm mostly expressing the output of
my predictive models about my creative
models and yeah yeah could I just
quickly press you on that so because you
I mean Grady was talking about your fear
earlier and you just said about reifying
complex emotions and turning them into a
into a scalar value I mean that doesn't
sound very scientific
well how do you think human minds work
so there is a there so when a when if I
was in World War II and you know one of
the greatest generals tell me I have a
feeling this is a bad idea this is going
to be an ambush we should do this do I
ask him don't talk about war Connor I've
studied it
I was hoping this would be one we could
agree on but
go down
I mean if I'm wrong please correct me
see I can get free gradients by just
being stupid in front of Grady and then
he corrects me it's so great it's it's
so convenient
um but like what I'm saying is is that
if an expert makes an intuition doesn't
have to be a War General we can say an
expert you know mathematician says I
think that I feel like this conjecture
is uh provable this is very common that
way before they have a proof a good in
math there's a lot of intuition that the
thing is provable this isn't I don't
think this is Magic I I think these are
fuzzy heuristics in the brain the same
way that like you know neural networks
will learn like a bunch of fuzzy
heuristics and some of these fuzzy
heuristics are useful it's important not
to
the useful thing about fuzzy heuristics
is not that you're supposed to dismiss
them it's not just because you're a
scientist you throw your intuition out
of the window of course not it's just
you are epistemologically clear about
what they are and how much you should
trust them and when you shouldn't trust
them and you're clear about what things
are affordable and what things are you
track your uncertainty so like yeah if
you know tomorrow it turned out that you
know some great paper came out that like
totally destroyed all my arguments about
why actually gbd4 is a total parlor
trick actually you know you know Sam
Altman had been hiring you know a
hundred thousand you know people to like
type really fast HD before or something
well then yeah I would be dead wrong
oh my God like yeah I'm dead wrong all
my intuitions were completely wrong and
you should listen to my intuitions
anymore because they were completely
calibrated they made their own
predictions
um so I don't yeah just one more Point
uh sorry just like on that point so it
is signal it doesn't mean it's truth you
know like intuitions are signal and then
you can do formal things on top of them
same thing is that formal things don't
mean they're true you know if there's a
long history of formally verified
cryptography that then got broken
because of you know wrong assumptions
that didn't actually apply to reality
I heard a signal of some thundering
Hooves and it's possible it might be a
zebra but it's very unlikely I think
you're worrying about zebras Connor
that seems like
that it's a reasonable intuition to have
okay let's go for another question
because we're running a little bit low
on time this is a question to you Grady
now um this person wondered the extent
to which llm hype is hindering progress
in embodied AI I'm a big fan of of the
embodied and the ecological traditions
and cognitive science and they said that
a lot of embodied AI tasks now are
basically just llms you know given
agentiveness or embodied or whatever so
it's kind of like a proxy for natural
language competency rather than the
traditional embodiment that we know and
love so what to what extent is it
hindering the the progress
well there's a general phenomena taking
place if you look at Venture Capital
funding in the valley right now uh large
language models Foundation models are
sucking the oxygen out of the air and I
think that's dangerous because it
basically it's pushing everybody in a
particular direction at the expense of
other things taking place not just
embodiment I think Venture capitals tend
to self-correct over time we're already
seeing some failures I mean part of
what's Happening Here is the barriers to
entry are so high for these companies it
costs so much just to get the
computational power to do anything to
compete against it and everybody else
that they're getting funded for seems to
be building layers on top of existing
large language models which means
they're building on top of sand that
they do not control we'll see how this
falls out but right now this the oxygen
in the air is getting sucked out and yes
indeed it is taking away from other
kinds of things I think it'll change
over time
okay okay thank you for that Grady
um a question to you Connor now this is
this is a really common question so try
and avoid giving the standard answer to
it but
um we can't even align people what makes
you think we can align Ai and I'm sure
Grady will have something to add on
there
if we could design humans from scratch
in a test tube and you know in a virtual
machine where we can test their brain
architecture over and over and we can
build mathematical theories about their
alerting and we could like design the
architecture from scratch then yeah I
think we could align humans
align them to the God creator of them
agreed so but the alignment we're
talking about is alignment of an ADI
with a parallel agency which is a very
different thing than the scenario you
described it would be like creating
those those creatures but then aligning
them with other species in the world so
I think what you're describing is vastly
different than the alignment problem
with which we're faced so I agree in the
sense that if we don't get to do this it
doesn't work yeah I expect we die I
expect if someone builds AGI and
releases it and then we have to line it
afterwards yeah we just die
well but hang on let's push him on this
because we're getting down to I think
some silliness if we create an fgi if
there are unicorns then the following
things will happen
so you again I think are speaking with
all due respect we're a point of fear
and a point a point of excruciating
improbability if there is an ADI I don't
know what an AGI is you've committed to
yourself earlier you don't know what AGI
is but if it's just some strange
Boogeyman that could do all these things
then this could happen
that's very unfair of you Grady because
earlier we talked about this exact topic
and you were very willing to entertain a
lot of the scenarios about the evil John
Von Newman's and whatever and now you're
gonna be backpacking on that that's kind
of unfair well let's go hang on let's
dial it back there Connor got it back I
did not say let's talk about what I said
because you misunderstood me I never
accepted there could be even a possible
scenario like that I said if this were
to happen now I'm talking about the
issue of could that even happen and the
answer is no the possibility is
excruciatingly asthmatotically close to
zero all right I mean if you believe
that then yes your report position is
reasonable okay okay
let's go into closing statements I'm
going to kind of um ask you a question
which you can um kind of dovetail into
your closing statement and I'm sure
you'll disagree with the framing this is
from someone in the comments but they
said I'd like to ask Grady
um whether you know what you consider
your strongest reason and is for for not
worrying about AI risk is it that it's
too far off that it will not be able to
kill us or that it will not want to kill
us so if you remember do that in your
your closing statements and then we'll
move over
well
to be clear I do not believe AI is an
existential risk I believe and I'm
disappointed that we didn't get to this
but look at the work of Bender and timet
and others who have talked about the
Clear and Present risks of AI we've
spent an hour we've spent 90 minutes on
things that I believe will never happen
in this particular Universe where we
have wasted those 90 minutes not
worrying about those things that are
impacting people here today and that is
the more important conversation so to
cure Point directly to Tim why do I not
fear super intelligence I believe it to
be so because first architecturally it
is implausible and furthermore whatever
we build is going to co-involve
co-evolve with us this is a systems
problem it's not that an alien drops an
AGI on us but we are evolving at the
same time we create those and I have
extreme confidence in the resilience and
goodness of the human spirit that says
we will co-evolve in ways that work well
for Humanity
thank you so much Grady and um Connor
over to you
yeah I just want to thank ready for the
great conversation I uh it's unfortunate
that we couldn't find uh more common
ground here and you know sorry that some
of the conversations that you want to
have did not get you know reached that's
unfortunate I do think these are
conversations worth having sorry that it
ended up going that way
um I think these are all very important
topics as I said at the beginning as
well I
I guess one of the things that's just
like I I think there are exactly two
times you can react to an exponential
too early or too late I think AI is an
exponential you seem to disagree with
that it was kind of we didn't really get
into this but from my perspective I
think
I guess I'm just less optimistic I think
the world's more fragile than you think
it is I think it is I think people are
less good at you know
adapting to things I think uh systems
and incentives are more ruthless I think
you know competition and uh you know
fight for survival are ruthless and more
powerful in many scenarios then maybe
you believe I don't know
um I might be wrong I I do not dismiss
the possibility that I'm wrong I think
there is a technical disagreement we
have about AGI I think a lot of this is
that I'm much more uncertain I am just
like I.E
I don't I I'm just not I'm nowhere near
as certain as you are in it not being
possible as I am in it being possible I
am less confident in anything possible
than you are and yet not being possible
so I I mean I think it's possible like
hypothetically like you know physics but
like it happened in like next five years
or ten years I think I'm much less
confident in that than it seems you are
that it won't happen this Century so I
think there is overlap here but I yeah
you know
I guess just I really found it
unfortunate that
um we use
um
when we have disagreements about models
and straightforward strategy that we
have to revert to things like oh you're
acting out of fear I don't like to
psychologizing considers to be Psycho
and psychoanalyzing this is not engaging
with the actual like average level
models this is just unfortunate
um so I think we did actually engage in
a lot of technical things and I really
appreciate your time for this so I
learned some things if you could send me
some stuff to learn more about war so
I'm less stupid about it next time I
would really appreciate that and just
say thank you so much for your time I
really really appreciate it yeah and let
me just say a couple of things as well
and first of all while I agree with
everything you said Grady about the
known knowns we've been talking about
the known unknowns
um they are extremely important but
please don't say this is a waste of 90
minutes I think that this has been
absolutely brilliant very pedagogical I
think a lot of the audience would have
learned a lot from this very very great
conversation between you two guys so I
really really appreciate it thank you so
much
thank you thank you honestly thank you
Grady so much for coming and obviously
Connor's you know good mates anyway but
um yeah in which case we'll close the
stream off um Folks at home I hope
you've enjoyed it as much as I have that
this is